bene tutti ragazzi perché questo video
cellophane i jazz fatti su scritto
appunto io con cap sport
oggi iniziamo solo con una parola che
devono indovinare i ragazzi e poi
iniziamo con un po di parole custom che
hanno fatto loro e non so 31 start che
mi dovete indovinare voi ragala vediamo
se la fatta disegnare a me non la fa
disegnare a casa quello che adesso tu la
lei brian per ti dirò la legge quella
parola c'era la delle parole davvero
grave allora mai io lo so fini non la
possa fare voglio vedere cosa mi invento
anche finisce con una sola ragazzi una
sola parola di segnala come solo tu sai
fare
lo capisci quest'anno camici 0 basta a
manas paolo ramo allora non so come
spiegare nessuno di queste va bene noi
siamo il asti meno male che ha scelto
quella che volevo scelta allora mano
brown un piede però sembra un muscolo
non saprei come spiegarlo sta faccenda è
molto più semplice indovinare fare ho
fatto con lui le ha fatte lui però vabbè
non importano ai ragazzi la fatte camper
ma chissà cosa è trattare i calli e però
non so come spiegarlo a sta facendo e
fetish ma solo con calma però quando
vuoi
comuni si è sprecato una passione
martello mai come allora aspetta dai
brut e bun inizia dai diciamo sempre di
pietro vabbè monopattino di gianpi te
sia bastava che lascia via di tutto
completamente bianco ma mi hai fatta
bellissimo ma che senso scusi posso
mettere altre cose la gente razzista
quindi preferiscono farlo ma cos'è quel
dopo avere un monopattino
no lo so che cos'è uno schifo un motore
quindi non è un monopattino quindi
infatti noi basta ma non ci sarebbe
arrivato neanche tra due ore allora
volete la parola semplice o quella
difficilissimi vendeva le fa ridere
entrambe agli omicidi stima perfetto il
colore a a caso in japan art
no ragazzi non ho idea ma andrea non può
essere facile se ci da disegni è infatti
è difficilissima loro hanno le chiavi
questo ci ha visto la parata si seconda
definisce a scampia
no io l'ho scritto e tu hai detto che vi
contestualizza luogo che cos'è la testa
e non è mai successa qui a indovinarla
fortissimo sacco di pyoor bravo a me
sembrava mehmedi browsers quando hai
disegnato trainer ieri
macché maliziosi che siete la gara di
[Musica]
niente
no ragazzi questa cosa qua non lo sa
nessuno
avellino potremo mai fare una bellissima
piani sfera era comunque era bovino
piccola bellissimo ma vadano a tutti
sapevano ha potuto scegliere le scritte
anche sapevo potevano sapere eva gli
iscritti no facciamo così a 50.000 nike
fa vj reagisce al terzo episodio di
batman palo ma va da sé non non posso
gli spiati non so chi è questo parli c'è
più in un mafioso o bocca che il passo è
breve ma cosa sta mangiando sta
mangiando il microfono poi fatti la
parola non meno non ci sta arrivando dai
questo ma bale tale madalin cosa vai a
capire chiuro dice parole di città new
york boston miami gerz tale ma fa solo
quello di tutto non dovevi mettere una
ragazza di per cava davanti ho scritto
dai a un cane che mangia un bambino
avrei scelto pietro non ho scelto io e
altri molto vaga questo è difficile
ah ah ok ok ma è qualcosa che fanno le
persone quando hanno un po pochi anni
sia giusto come ho fatto ad azzeccarle
dai grandissimo non ci posso credere
gli manca il primo porte regalata ai è
capito dai paletti ma la faccio pure di
colore diverso il movimento del braccio
mancava un secondo si limita cassa da
morto
il canale di pietro hx 49 un po troppo
capito dicevo che ora non è più così
però piero la rai non ho capito lo giuro
che però per questo nessuno di estranei
prega io ho capito aiuto ea me va a
cagare da noi non stavo capendo anno
quella fatta io vedo che ha più penso
fosse un cerchio dietro e cos'è cos'è
che stavano la pitbull non parrocato
ritiro per bambini
capita allora è uno sport uno sport in
cui ti butti quindi quindi quindi pangea
jumping quindi perfetto
manca però qualcosa quindi senza cosa
porta verona comandante della corda non
accorda a un suo nome come hai fatto a
fare sta roba
ma cos'è cos'è bellissimo ma ci tengo
inquadrato come non affatto campate una
serie tv è come si scrive alla domanda
avvocato anch'io prodotti amadori
sbaglia ratio è la via giusta è anche
secondo me è giusto infatti è sbagliato
tutto sbagliato scrive come si scherza
sembra una pizza col formaggio scaduto
in realtà è il simbolo della
radioattività ma anche senza l'acca dai
come senza la maschera e ad attivare
qualcuno grazie a parole ne andiamo e la
radioattività gli ha portato via la hp è
una gru gamer
no è un maschio infatti ci faccio un po
di vento nei capelli anche che insieme a
un po di un suo nei capelli
è una pillola trovato indovinare è
secondo me la cavo lisone i capelli ho
capito subito
mancano i chili bowl indicazioni per noi
possono quattro lettere ragazze dai
ragazzi la partita era difficile caridi
pistorius ha un altro ma cosa regate
giuro che io non ho scritto niente si
guarda l'indice della prima rete ormai
chiedermi se niente dai facciamo esso in
fondo i palloni usciti a indovinarlo
alla vibrata per cui padella macchine
salva finisse con lei ma l'ho detto io
ci sarà tutto dall'altra la presa ma
sono io questo non sono io no
dopo darsi no la mia faccio ancora scusa
ora secondo a chi è mai fatto pure il
pene no no no no è un errore ama food
[Musica]
cia le cuffie ha così l'abbiamo scritta
noi perché tu hai sbagliato ma dai sei
arrivato secondo in tutto questo a
proposito di bandella sono rigidi altro
cielo anche il video
ragazzi siete un'emozione posso dirvelo
grazie
e non possiamo più felice però vi
ringrazio questa era un bel punto io con
gli iscritti al canale passate del
canale in descrizione schiacciate a
campanella che rimani aggiornato su
tutti i video che escono e noi ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]